tf1 20 heures avec roger gicquel il
avait fait marcher l'homme sur la lune
wernher von braun est mort aujourd'hui
d'un cancer le sommet franco-allemand
paris et bonn d'accord sur l'énergie
nucléaire
pierre mauroy ou congrès du parti
socialiste il faut nous préparer pour
une échéance historique celle du pouvoir
son président arrive demain en visite
officielle à paris
le costa rica un pays qui veut vivre
sans armée bonsoir l'homme de l'espace
est mort je veux dire l'homme sans qui
l'espace c'est à dire sa découverte par
les hommes ne seraient sans doute pas ce
qu'elle est l'homme qui fit marche et
d'autres hommes sur la lune
bien que ces premiers engins furent
moins estimable mais c'était la guerre
c'était les v2 allemand vous l'avez
compris c'est de monsieur wernher von
braun qu'il s'agit le pionnier de
l'espace vient en effet de mourir aux
états unis victime d'un cancer il avait
65 ans il est décédé à washington outre
les v2 les enfants de bonne de von braun
vous les connaissez apollo jupiter
saturne donc von braun est un homme déjà
de notre mythologie prométhée enchaîné
qui voulaient atterrir sur l'olympe sans
doute carrière fabuleuse en tout cas
françois crozet
oui certainement von braun c'est l'homme
d'une passion tenu par une passion
depuis son enfance
et l'homme qui la réalise en poursuivant
son idée comme un somnambule sans voir
le paysage qu'il traverse
et de fait il faut reconnaître que dans
les années 1930
le voyage sur la lune était réservée aux
auteurs de science-fiction c'était un
sujet pour les films d'anticipation des
chats le fils du baron magnus von braun
lui bricoler des fusées avec des pompes
de bicyclettes et ce n'était pas
seulement un rêve d'enfant car à 20 ans
le gouvernement allemand le nomme à la
tête du programme des fusées à la
station expérimentale de kums stuff et à
25 ans il est directeur technique du
centre des fusées du paint moon en
allemagne et l'allemagne est sous la
domination des nazis hitler seul croit
aux fusées von braun armes donc les
nazis pour poursuivre son rêve de la
fusée et il met au point successivement
d'abord la v2 et puis
surtout la v1 et puis surtout la p2 et
là c'est la véritable première fusée
fusée hélas militaire qui ravagera
londres on frémit en songeant à ce qui
se serait passé si claire avait cru à la
bombe atomique
autant qu'elle a fusé regardez cette
fusée c'est la première de l'histoire
des hommes
hélas une fusée militaire mais à la fin
de la guerre
von braun et son équipe choisissent
leurs vainqueurs il se livre aux
américains qui d'ailleurs n'apprécie
guère ce cadeau
les russes eux croient tout de suite à
l'espace et sont les premiers à lancer
un spoutnik
alors que les fusées américaines échoue
tandis que se développent triomphante
l'astronautique soviétique
les américains n'ont que des v2
améliorée car ils n'ont pas cru aux
rêves de von braun et les premiers
essais de satellisation américain se
traduise par de nouvelles humiliations
l'humiliation pamplemousse après
l'humiliation satellite souvenez-vous
l'amérique semble incapable de mettre au
point ces fusées mais ces fusées que
vous voyez exploser ce ne sont pas les
fusées de von braun et c'est lui qui va
sauver l'honneur des américains en
lançant ce satellite le premier explorer
avec sa fusée jupiter sait et il faudra
encore longtemps avant que l'amérique
croit véritablement à l'espace avec le
président kennedy qui va lancer le
programme apollo et enfin voici la fusée
devant prône la fusée de ses rêves la
saturn 5
ce monstre qui permettra d'envoyer trois
hommes sur la lune
voyez cette fusée elle est véritablement
dérivé de la filière v2
redstone jupiter c'est bien la fusée
conçu par von braun à la tête du centre
des vols habités de houston il est donc
un des grands responsables du programme
apollo
seulement dès 1967 c'est le drame trois
astronautes meurent brûlés vifs dans la
cabine au cours d'une répétition et à
cette époque j'avais raconte rencontré
von braun kim avait exprimé sa confiance
dans la suite du programme
finalement à quelle durée chiffré vous
de retard pourrait résulter pour le
programme apollo
si vous regardez l'ensemble du programme
il se pourrait qu'il n'y ait pas de
retard mais pour ce qui concerne les
volumes en retard rod est d'environ six
mois oui cet optimisme pouvait paraître
excessif ils n'étaient que le réalisme
d'un ingénieur sûr de sa technique
et de fait nous allons assister à la
grande victoire de l'homme sur la lune
de l'homme sur l'espace à la victoire
américaine cette fois et c'est toujours
von braun à houston qui commente la
grande épopée américaine seulement
tandis que le programme apollo déploie
ses fastes et bien déjà l'espace change
de direction
von braun plaide pour que l'on aille au
delà d'apollo qu'on fasse des fusées
plus grande que l'on prépare déjà le
voyage vers mars
mais en fait l'amérique va relâcher son
effort et alors en brawn va quitter la
nasa il va passer dans l'industrie
privée
oui d'un côté l'amérique triomphante
poursuit ses vols vers la lune mais déjà
elle a abandonné le rêve de von braun de
conquérir mars après la lune
déjà elle prépare une astronautique plus
modeste plus utile avec la navette
spatiale et von braun secrètement
caressait un dernier rêve
l'ultime aboutissement de sa passion
c'était d'être lui même un jour en
orbite
il avait même parlé rêver qu'un jour
avec le président des états unis ils
seraient tous les deux en orbite et bien
non l'espace ne s'est pas développé
assez rapidement on savait depuis
plusieurs mois que paul braun était
atteint d'un cancer
ce rêve le dernier il ne leur a pas
réalisé mais avec sa passion il en a
réalisé vécu tellement d'autres pour
nous tous et la navette spatiale
américaine qui devait être essayé
aujourd'hui et bien a dû rester au sol
l'essai est reporté à demain le peuple
du monde entier a bénéficié des travaux
de wernher von braun nous continue
continueront à tirer profit de son
exemple c'est ce qu'écrit le président
des états unis dans un texte publié dès
l'annoncé de sa mort
il n'est pas sorti de grande fusée du
sommet franco allemand mais tout de même
quelques décisions et quelques phrases
importante parmi les propos celui de
monsieur giscard d'estaing évoquant la
confédération de l'europe et c'est
relativement nouveau comme expression en
tout cas et parmi les décisions
l'accord de l'allemagne pour l'étude
avec la france et d'autres pays non pas
d'un engin spatial en mémoire de vente
brown et plus prosaïquement d'un avion
moyen-courrier bien utile pour
l'industrie aéronautique européenne
l'idée a été lancée il ya quelques jours
par la france et autres décisions plus
importante
l'allemagne fédérale va mettre l'embargo
jusqu'à nouvel ordre sur l'exportation
d'installation de retraitement du
combustible nucléaire
cela harmonise pratiquement la politique
allemande nucléaire et la politique
française mais ça ne remet pas en cause
un contrat de l'allemagne déjà signé
avec le brésil
notre envoyé spécial à bonn gérard
simple ce sommet franco allemand avait
commencé vous le savez en tout cas la
presse le disait un peu dans la
grisaille est bien le président
république au cours d'une conférence de
presse commune vient de dire que ce 30e
sommet franco-allemand ne connaissait
pas de résultat sensationnel
il n'ya d'ailleurs jamais de résultat
sensationnel dans de telles réunions
mais il a fait des progrès substantiels
le chancelier allemand helmut schmidt de
son côté a parlé de compréhension intime
entre les deux gouvernements ne vous
méprenez pas sur le mot intimes at il
dit aux journalistes
en effet après un déjeuner au château
dernier après une nouvelle séance
plénière le résultat concret que l'on
attendait plus a été donnée à la
connaissance des journalistes et il
porte sur l'énergie nucléaire
en effet le gouvernement fédéral dans
une déclaration unilatérale
aujourd'hui même a décidé de rendre
publique sa position sur le problème de
la non prolifération de l'énergie
nucléaire et il est intéressant de
constater que cette déclaration
correspond mais presque mot pour mot à
la position française défini récemment
au cours des cinq conseils de l'énergie
nucléaire à l'elysée voilà donc paris et
bonn et notamment vis-à-vis des
américains sur la même base de
discussions en effet les deux points
principaux de cette déclaration disent
que dans la perspective des
développements d'énergie nucléaire
le gouvernement fédéral ne délivrera pas
jusqu'à nouvel ordre
d'autorisation pour l'exportation
d'installation et de technologie de
retraitement cette mesure n'affecte ni
les traités existants ni leurs
applications cela signifie en clair
aussi que les contrats en cours seront
honorés en prenant ces décisions
deuxième point le gouvernement fédéral
part du principe que les arrangements
conclus dans le passé sur la fourniture
de combustible nucléaire et autre
matériel nécessaire à l'utilisation
pacifique seront respectés et bien cela
correspond le président de la république
l'a dit exactement je vous le disais à
la position française
voici d'ailleurs en conclusion ce qu'a
déclaré le président de la république à
l'issue de ce 30ème sommet franco
allemand
monsieur le président un journal de
munich écrivait il ya deux jours il n'y
a plus de relations privilégiées entre
paris et bonn qui d'ailleurs ne les
souhaite plus est-ce que c'est exact et
quel est votre bilan
ce 30e sommet franco-allemand dans le
pessimisme n'a jamais eu aucune raison
d'être la règle de la vérité et ce 30e
sommet franco-allemand a montré au
contraire le caractère très important je
ne veux pas dire plus légers très
important des relations
franco-allemandes d'abord je crois qu'il
existe pas dans le monde à l'heure
actuelle deux pays qui ont des relations
aussi régulière est aussi organisée que
l'allemagne que la france est notre part
il faut naturellement prendre acte du
fait qu'au fur à mesure que notre
coopération se développe les choses
deviennent de plus en plus naturelle est
de plus en plus habituel quand deux pays
se réconcilient cdh allure sensationnel
quand deux pays travaillent ensemble
comme quand deux voisins travaillent
ensemble cela devient la vie naturelle
et donc la coopération franco-allemande
est entré maintenant dans la nature
profonde de nos relations et je m'en
réjouis mais sur un des plus grands
sujets qui se posent au monde actuel et
au monde de demain
nous avons plus à l'occasion de ce
sommet franco-allemand de bonnes faire
un progrès décisif et je veux dire la
similitude des politiques de l'allemagne
et de la france concernant le problème
de l'énergie nucléaire son usage et les
précautions à prendre en matière de
prolifération
c'est le président n'avez vous pas
craint un blocage de la construction
européenne avec tous ces débats autour
de l' élection du parlement européen au
suffrage universel
je n'ai jamais craint ce blocage j'ai
reçu pendant tout l'hiver et grand
nombre de journalistes et j'aurai
toujours
dit que l'élection au suffrage universel
des membres de l'assemblée parlementaire
européenne serait approuvée par le
parlement français
j'ai de très nombreux témoins et vous
avez noté qu'à l'assemblée nationale il
s'est trouvé aucun groupe
je dis bien aucun groupe ni dans
l'opposition ni dans la majorité pour
prendre l'initiative d'une position
contre et donc voici la première étape
franchie la seconde étape très
importante va être le débat au sénat
et je suis persuadé que l'ensemble du
parlement français ratifiera cette
décision importante pour l'avenir de
l'europe et je vous rappelle que
l'allemagne fédérale a procédé de la
même manière que nous c'est à dire
qu'hier le bundestag qui est
l'équivalent de notre assemblée
nationale a ratifié à l'unanimité cet
accord merci monsieur prison
et puisque tout à l'heure nous étions
dans l'espace restant via un instant on
a lancé aujourd'hui le 18e satellite
français 103 kg il s'appelle il
s'appelle signe 3 mais ce qui est
important c'est que c'est le troisième
satellite français lancés par une fusée
soviétique et à bord de signes 3-2
expérience dont l'une va tenter de
localiser les grands nuages de poussière
qui dérivent dans l'espace des nuages
qui sont soit les cendres du soleil soit
la pâte avec laquelle il se fabriquera
de nouvelles étoiles signe trois se
porte bien dit on il aura des
descendants puisque d'autres expériences
françaises seront faites à partir de ce
satellite soviétique et même à partir de
sonde pour venus de quoi réjouir
monsieur giscard d'estaing et léonid
brejnev qui vous le savez est attendu à
paris la semaine prochaine
cette coopération vraiment au sommet se
concrétise trois jours avant le voyage
du chef de l'état soviétique mais
peut-être aussi coïncidence en hommage à
von braun
au congrès du parti socialiste français
a nantes les 15 cents délégués du parti
de françois mitterrand ce sont donc
réunis pour un congrès de l'unité qui
est aussi une rampe de lancement pour
les élections de mars
78 un parti qui selon pierre mauroy qui
a ouvert les débats approche d'une
situation dominante dans le pays
mais il faut d'abord régler les
problèmes internes sur cette première
journée
notre envoyé spécial bruno masure le
premier secrétaire du ps est arrivée au
congrès cet après midi au moment où les
choses sérieuses commencent et la
discussion entre sa motion et la motion
signée jean pierre chevènement soutenu
par 25% des militants me serais semblent
disposés aux concessions sur son
fonctionnement en tant qu'organisation
mais des divergences politiques subsiste
encore avec la majorité sur le rôle du
parti au pouvoir
l'europe la planification ou encore les
nationalisations tout le monde en tout
cas est d'accord le ps doit être un
parti de gouvernement rejetait les
ambiguïtés d'une fausse unanimité et au
contraire rechercher la cohésion
politique comme l'a rappelé tire mon jeu
essentiel du congrès de nantes et de
nous préparer à une échéance historique
celle du pouvoir et nous sommes ici
rassemblés pour trois jours autour de
deux thèmes qui seront essentielles
celle de notre unité qui n'est
d'ailleurs pas en cause mais je suis
persuadé que tous les délégués qui sont
là sont là pour montrer à tous combien
le parti socialiste est cohérent
combien il réunit et combien il tient à
sa cohésion
et nous sommes là également pour montrer
combien notre organisation est
responsable responsable du socialisme
dans ce pays responsables de notre parti
mais responsables aussi avec les autres
formations de la gauche
et si le français le souhaitent de la
france et des français
actuellement la salle est pratiquement
vide il ya une alerte à la bombe ici
apparemment fausse alerte
la commission des résolutions il réunit
pour savoir si on peut parvenir à une
synthèse entre les deux motions la base
semble-t-il le souhait de la réponse en
tout cas est entre les mains de françois
mitterrand
réponse vendredi samedi soir ou dimanche
matin et puis ce soir ce sera comme dans
les grandes conventions américaines la
fête à nantes pour les socialistes une
fête marquée surtout par l'hymne composé
par theodorakis lequel sera présent à
nantes au congrès socialiste la
délégation espagnole a été accueillie
par des ovations pour célébrer son
succès d'après un journal madrilène de
l'après-midi juan carlos a confirmé dans
ses fonctions de a été confirmé dans ses
fonctions de président du gouvernement
non pardon juan carlos a confirmé dans
ses fonctions de président du
gouvernement monsieur adolfo soares la
d2 vainqueur des élections générales et
monsieur soares aurait présenté sa
démission conformément à ce qui était
convenu hier mais le souverain aurait
refusé lui aurait bien sûr demandé de
demeurer à la tête du gouvernement en y
apportant les changements qu'il désirait
monsieur soares et l'union du centre
démocratique avec ses 5 millions de voix
et ses 168 sièges pour l'instant deux
députés n'a pas la majorité absolue
mais il est le premier et il doit tenir
compte maintenant d'un courant
socialiste exactement équivalent les
chiffres le démontrent de plus en plus
et qui a peut être même une légère
supériorité en nombre d'électeurs
sinon en nombre de sièges sur le centre
en effet le parti socialiste ouvrier
espagnol à environ 4 millions 600 mille
voix et 116 députés
si l'on compte dans ce courant
socialiste le parti catalan où la petite
formation le psp on arrive actuellement
une supériorité du courant socialiste
sur le centre d'environ 1 2%
et alors que les résultats définitifs ne
sont pas encore publiés
à noter aussi le score des communistes
qui n'a cessé de monter depuis hier un
million cinq cent mille voix mais
seulement 19 sièges et puis tout n'a pas
été pour le mieux dans ce dépouillement
premières critiques de la presse le
quotidien libéral de gauche el país
regrette très fort que deux jours après
les élections le gouvernement n'ait pas
été capable de donner des résultats
dignes de foi cent vingt mille électeurs
qui n'ont pas pu accomplir leur devoir
électoral hier par suite
avant-hier par suite d'erreurs de
procédure ont voté aujourd'hui résultats
définitifs annoncés vers le 20 juin 21
juin jacques greene au du moulin de
retour dès ce 1 6 pour monsieur suarez
et son union du centre sur le plan des
suffrages les résultats ne sont pas
aussi brillant qu'on ne le laissait
supposer hier officiellement le premier
ministre ne devance plus que de très peu
monsieur felipe gonzalez
le secrétaire du parti socialiste en
obtenant seulement trois et demi pour
cent de votants plus alors que hier
quelques 12 à 13 points les séparaient
au congrès cela ne change pas grand
chose à la répartition des sièges car ce
n'est pas le système proportionnel pure
qui est appliquée mais pour le leader
socialiste
tout cela fait une grande différence
pour l'instant après tout le saut et de
monsieur felipe gonzalez ne fait que
quatre cent mille voix de moins que
l'union du centre et son jeune leader a
tout lieu de ne pas être satisfait de la
façon dont le ministère de l'intérieur
espagnol a publié les résultats
électoraux en escamotant littéralement
les succès socialiste afin sans doute de
tranquilliser l'opinion du mois une
certaine opinion publique espagnole
ainsi la victoire de monsieur suarez
sera t-elle apparu très large
alors qu'en réalité seul le système
électoral la proportionnelle par
circonscription sans répartition des
restes à l'échelon national
seul ce système aura permis au premier
ministre d'obtenir au congrès 167 sièges
contre quelque 117 seulement au parti
socialiste ouvrier espagnol
quand on parle des relations de la
france avec les autres états ont
évidemment l'accent sur ses relations
avec deux grands pays puissant sur le
plan économique et politique mais les
relations internationales ce n'est pas
que cela
nous avons aussi de tout petit pays
parmi nos amis
le costa rica par exemple dont le
président sera reçu demain par valéry
giscard d'estaing est petit par la
taille et la population 2 millions
d'habitants et il est dans le cordon
ombilical qui relie les deux amériques
entre nicaragua et panama mais il est
grand par sa réputation d'organisation
sociale et puis surtout le costa rica a
une particularité qu'on trouve rarement
dans le monde
il n'a pas d'armée bien qu'il est une
police
comme partout christian brincourt s'en
est rendu compte sur place
le costa rica est l'un des rares pays au
monde qui ne possèdent pas d'arriver ici
dans ce petit pays de deux millions
d'habitants au centre de l'amérique
centrale
on constate une absence totale
d'aviation de bâtiments de guerre quand
à la marine est bien entendu l'armée de
terre la sécurité du pays est assurée
par une police municipale voire
militaire vous pouvez avoir un aperçu
derrière moi ce contraste est d'autant
plus spectaculaire que l'amérique
centrale comme chacun sait est dirigé en
grande partie par des juntes militaires
pour l'étranger qui visitent le costa
rica donc il est surprenant de constater
cette absence totale de militaires cela
dit après la loi de 48 ans abolissant
cette armée une police militaire a été
créé cette dernière assure une vigilance
de tous les instants
le gouvernement est populaire
représentatif est rééligible tous les
quatre ans la défense du territoire est
donc assurée par un corps a restreint de
garder civile 2500 hommes tout en même
temps responsable de la sécurité
intérieure et de l'ordre public
mais que se passerait-il en cas de crise
grave voire de guerre au costa rica
nous l'avons demandé au président de la
république du costa rica le président
daniel audoubert pensons que nous avons
fait les transformations des
costaricains fin de vie sociale parce
que nous n'avons pas dormi
il n'y a pas des établissments à côté de
la france politique est un pays petit du
pays n'a pas besoin d'armes et non parce
qu'elle se tendent et pensent que nous
ne vous donne pas faire gémir et
dépenser les grosses sommes dans la
location de la santé qui est difficile
et quand même si nous avons une guerre
il y aller le traité entre américain et
mondial qui nous donne de protection
immédiat mais nous pouvons téléphoner un
pays voisin un grand pays voisins et
nous sommes sûrs que nous avons
défendues par an nous allons protéger
pour développer la création à la
télévision un thème qui a fait beaucoup
beaucoup parler les journaux spécialisés
une partie du public un thème qui il est
vrai est d'un très grand intérêt
essentiel pour vous téléspectateurs
henri caillavet sénateur du
lot-et-garonne a fait ce matin une
proposition au sénat au cours des
questions orales au gouvernement donnant
un coup de pouce aux budgets des
télévisions a dit à peu près henri
caillavet il a proposé en tout cas une
rallonge de 200 millions de francs mais
affecté un fonds spécial pour la
création en 1970 ce pour cinq mille deux
cents heures de télévision
grosso modo en valeur d' approche il y
avait quatre cent trente trois heures de
création de fiction c'est à dire d'être
original avec 1200 heures de plus de
programmation en 1976
nous n'avons plus que 250 heures de
création de fiction ceci est très
dangereux au regard de la sfp débute sur
mon fils n'y a plus de plan de charge et
que partant les prix les serments de
leurs augmente lorsque elle livre sa
production par ailleurs sont en chômage
les réalisateurs sont en chômage partiel
les artistes bref tous ceux qui font la
télévision alors je propose au
gouvernement de bien vouloir se soucier
de cette difficulté et je lui propose la
création d'un fonds d'un fonds spécial
un peu à l'exemple du fonds culturel ou
de l'aide apportée aux livres en tant
que fond du livre et doter ce fonds nous
sommes suffisamment importante 200
millions grosso modo pour d'une part
permettre au ministre des affaires
culturelles de subventionner les deux
chaînes les deux sociétés de programmes
et en même temps commander à la ssp pour
le compte et le profit de ces mêmes
chaînes des dramatiques des oeuvres
originales et des heures de fiction car
à tout prendre
la finalité de la télévision c'est le
divertissement et le divertissement
culturel c'est bien en bref les autres
nouvelles de ce journal avec vos jambes
burqa à commencer par la faire revenir
beaumont le 13 avril dernier jour de
l'enlèvement du pdg de fiat france
hector ariste y étaient au pakistan
c'est ce qu'a déclaré aujourd'hui
l'épousé du suspect numéro 1 madame
aristide
journaliste de l'agencé france presse
pour le reste on se prépare apparemment
un nouveau week-end attente les
policiers ce matin paraissait confiant
il semble en tout cas persuadé que
monsieur revelli beaumont est toujours
bien vivant les députés en ont décidé
ainsi hier soir écouter bien le seul
fait d'être surpris en état d'ébriété au
volant d'une voiture annulera désormais
le permis de conduire il s'agit bien
d'une annulation et non d'un simple
retrait ou une suspension en effet dans
le cas de conduite en état d'ivresse il
faudra effectivement repasser le permis
d'autre part la police a désormais le
droit de faire subir l'alcootest à toute
personne qui sort d'un débit de boisson
et qui s'apprête à monter dans une
voiture
autres décisions prises à l'assemblée
nationale hier soir le congé paternel
après une naissance dans la famille
désormais représente heureux événement
la mer mais aussi le père aura le droit
de prendre deux ans de congé sans solde
avec réintégration automatique dans
l'entreprise à l'issue de cette période
cependant il faut le préciser ce congé
s'applique soit au pair soit la mer mais
jamais aux deux époux en même temps le
mensuel pour les travailleurs manuels il
s'appelle d'ailleurs ainsi que vous
pouvez le voir le travailleur manuel son
premier numéro que l'on trouve
aujourd'hui dans les kiosques a été tiré
à 400 mille exemplaires et coûtent deux
fronts michel d'ornano
michel d'ornano a défini pour la
première fois aujourd'hui devant le
sénat les grandes orientations de sa
politique culturelle le ministre de la
culture a prononcé à plusieurs reprises
les mots de liberté diversité et
pluralisme
monsieur d'ornano accordera une priorité
absolue à la restauration des monuments
historiques en matière de cinéma
le ministre a réaffirmé le principe de
l'abolition de la censure mais il a
aussi précisé qu'il ne tolérerait pas la
présentation de films portant gravement
atteinte à la personne humaine
le voyage de madame valérie giscard
d'estaing en corse hier l'épousé du
président de la république s'est
intéressé au problème des jeunes
handicapés et a visité aussi une maison
de retraite
aujourd'hui madame giscard d'estaing a
axé sa visite autour des problèmes
touristique de l'île de beauté
le syndicat national des instituteurs
poursuit son offensive contre la réforme
haby le sni qui regroupe plus de 85% des
instituteurs en france a réaffirmé
aujourd'hui au cours d'une conférence de
presse sa volonté de ne
appliquée à la prochaine rentrée
scolaire les instructions prévu par la
réforme
les jeux olympiques seront désormais
confié un pays et non plus à une ville
c'est une décision prise aujourd'hui par
le comité olympique international
ce nouveau règlement pourrait entrer en
vigueur dès l'an prochain pour la
désignation des jeux de 1984 ouverture
hier soir à lisbonne de la conférence
mondiale contre l'apartheid le racisme
et le colonialisme en afrique australe
dans un message à la conférence
cordevalle d'eim secrétaire général des
nations unies a affirmé que si le
gouvernement sud-africain persiste dans
sa politique actuelle
l'onu devra se tenir prêtes à prendre
les mesures appropriées
le tiercé de dimanche se courra à
auteuil dans la 4e course une épreuve de
haies avec 19 partants rendez vous
demain à 13 heures avec jean claude
bourret et andré théron enfin cette
dernière information et général de
brigade suisse condamné à 18 ans de
réclusion criminelle il a été jugé
coupable d'espionnage au profit de
l'union soviétique le général jean louis
jean maire a fourni pendant plusieurs
années de nombreux documents et des
informations intéressant la défense
nationale suisse à moscou
le temps vient pour ce que j'en ai vu
aujourd'hui et vu d'avion c'est
d'ailleurs très agréable entre poitiers
et paris est bien les brumes elle
tardait à se dissiper le soleil et
beaucoup de mal à percer b demain ce
sera un peu la même chose sur les
régions situées au nord de la loire le
temps sera très nuageux et brumeux avec
des plus éparses et sur les régions de
l'est
on prévoit brouillard le matin suivi
d'éclaircies tu ne m'intéressant sur le
reste du pays aura également des bancs
de brouillard le matin de belles
périodes ensoleillées dans le courant de
la journée
mais des orages se produiront dans
l'après midi et pourront devenir violent
attention au voisinage des massifs au
sommet franco-allemand dont nous avons
parlé tout à l'heure le président de la
république a parlé de cette
confédération de l'europe qui devrait
combler le vide que l'europe a creusé
elle même depuis le début du siècle par
ces affrontements fratricides
dans le même temps devant cette
université gutenberg de mayence dont on
fête le 5 le cinquième centenaire le
président la république fédérale
d'allemagne parlait de la résistance
française comme de l'une des premières
fondations d'une politique d'entente
avec l'allemagne libérée du joug
hitlérien
propos solennel et qui nous rappelle
ceci 37 ans déjà le temps s'éloigne le
souvenir reste très fort iran n'est fait
37 ans demain qu au micro de la bbc le
général de gaulle lançait l'appel
historique du 18 juin 40 pour demander
aux français de ne pas accepter
l'armistice et de continuer la lutte
pour la liberté
l'appel avait été rédigée dans un
immeuble de londres aux quatre carlton
gardens et taper sur cette machine à
écrire qui est l'une des pièces
historiques de l'institut charles de
gaulle à paris et demain des
personnalités françaises de la
résistance se retrouveront dans le
studio reconstitué de la bbc avec le
vrai micro ou a été lancé l'appel
n'oublions pas qu aux yeux de ses chefs
militaires et du gouvernement de
l'époque le soldat charles de gaulle
devenait un dissident mais il avait le
sentiment de parler déjà au nom de la
france de gaulle était presque seul ce
jour là sans moyens sans armée et
pourtant vous connaissez la suite
kristen delacroix et crée en quelques
heures
l'appel lancé par une voix venue de
londres à les concrétiser
la résistance l'intérêt supérieur de la
patrie commandes à tous les français
libres de continuer le combat
là où ils seront et comme ils pourront
moi général de gaulle
j'entreprends ici en angleterre 70
nationale j'invite tous les français
ils veulent rester libre à m'écouter et
à me suivre
et bien cet appel était la chute des
événements qui s'étaient poursuivies
pendant les jours précédents car il
avait fait tous ses efforts comme
secrétaire d'état à la défense pour
entraîner le gouvernement vole reynaud à
poursuivre la guerre en afrique du nord
ou montherlant ou quelque part dans l'
empire vous avez été le grand témoin de
la conception et de l'élaboration de cet
appel est ce que ça a été véritablement
un acte solitaire traiter vraiment
l'acte solitaire
si personne ne prône une
actif et bien de boules la prendre un
seul pour que la france reste dans la
guerre c'est ça en plein air la
signification de l'appel du 18 juin où
il avait accompagné au studio de la bbc
vous leur premier la bbc ou esquiver
l'impression à ce moment là d'avoir
accompli un acte historique qui devait
être changé le destin de la france pour
lui certainement c'était un grand pas
est un acte de très grande importance
mais encore une fois il ne pouvait pas
même si le pressentait dire ce jour là
toute la france va me suive car son
snack appel aurait pu sombrer dans
l'indifférence
si ça n'avait pas été de gaulle sédogo
l'enfant qui était l'homme du destin le
18 juin 40 sera commémorée demain de
deux façons d'abord au mont valérien où
mémorial de la france combattante
monsieur giscard d'estaing présidera la
cérémonie est organisée par l'ordre de
la libération en présence des membres du
gouvernement
cela à 19h15 nous vous en rendrons
compte d'ailleurs dans notre journal qui
sera noté le bien exceptionnellement
avancée à 19h23 et puis un peu plus tôt
à 18 heures cérémonie à l'arc de
triomphe le maire de paris jacques
chirac a lancé un appel à la population
parisienne de toutes les commémorations
que propose notre histoire dit il aucune
n'a de valeur plus haute que celle du 18
juin et il souhaite évidemment que les
parisiens soient nombreux à l'arc de
triomphe pour la série mini la cérémonie
officielle présidée par andré bord
secrétaire d'état aux anciens
combattants
un mot encore je vous ai dit que notre
journal de la soirée comment serait
beaucoup plus tôt c'est-à-dire 19h23
mais la raison impérative c'est qu'à 20
heures il y aura la retransmission de la
finale de la coupe de france
saint-etienne reims en exclusivité sur
tf1 commentaire pire quand johnny jean
raynal en direct du parc des princes
voilà bonne soirée à tous dernier
journal jean pierre pernaut 22h50 fin de
programme merci